Transcriber: Emre Incel
Gözden geçirme: Nihal Aksakal
Merhabalar, hoş geldiniz.
Benim için de bir ilk, TED konuşması.
Salon'da olması ve bu samimiyet çok güzel.
Şimdi her şey İhtiyaç Haritası
ile başladı
ve ben, İhtiyaç Haritası için buradayım.
Ben biraz kısaca kendimden bahsedeyim.
Bu ihtiyaç haritası nasıl oluştu?
Çünkü benimle de ilgili
bir durum aynı zamanda.
Çok küçük yaşta sosyal sorumluluk
çalışmalarına başladım.
Halk Evleri ile sonra devamında
bu gelişti ve okullarda da ortaokul
ve lise hayatım boyunca
devam eden çalışmalar oldu.
İstanbul'a taşındıktan sonra da
birçok dernekle çalışmaya başladım.
İçlerinde TEGV'in, AÇEV'in de olduğu
birçok STK dernekle çalıştım
ve sahada da çalışmalar yürüttüm.
Akabinde yine başka bir çalışma için
Elif Kalan adında bir arkadaşımla
tanıştım ve çalışmaya başladık.
Aslında bu genç yaşta insanların
siyasete atılmasıyla ilgili bir projeydi.
Sonra o proje için
sahada da çalışmalar yürüttük.
Devamında biz Elif'le bu yaptığımız
sosyal sorumluluk çalışmalarını,
paylaşmaya başladık.
Ama öyle bir hal aldı ki hem dizilerden
hem reklamlardan, filmlerden,
birçok sosyal sorumluluk
çalışmasına çağrılmaya başladım.
Onların video çalışmaları, onların
beyin fırtınası çalışmaları,
ajans çalışmaları gibi, bir çoğunda hem
fikir bazında, hem uygulama bazında,
bu işe yatkın arkadaşlarımızla birlikte
güç birliği yapmak üzere birçok
çalışmada bulundum.
Fakat belli bir zaman
sonra yetişememeye başladım
ve benim ihtiyacım aslında şuydu:
Bu çalışmaları, bu ihtiyaçları,
bu sivil toplum örgütlerinin geliştirdiği
programları keşke bir
bütün halinde görebilsem.
Keşke bir site olsa.
İller bazında bunları o sitede görebilsem.
Kim nerede? Ne yapıyor?
Birileri çünkü bir günlüğüne bir şehre
gidiyor ya da yeni geldiği bir şehirde
o sivil toplum kuruluşu ile
irtibata geçmemiş oluyor.
Hızlıca irtibata geçirecek
bir sistemdi hayalim.
Sonra Elif beni Ali Özgür ile tanıştırdı.
Ali Özgür Ercan da uzun
yıllar sahada böyle çalışmalar yapmış.
Sivil toplum kuruluşları
ile çalışmalar yapmış.
Siyaset bilimi okumuş.
Üstüne bu konuda master ve doktora yapmış.
Aramızdaki tek doktor.
Biz dört kurucu üyeyiz aslında.
Yeri gelmişken onu da söyleyeyim.
Elif Kalan, Ali Ercan
Özgür ve Güler Altınsoy.
Hepsi de çokça çalışma yaptıkları
için bu konuda bilgililerdi.
Biz dedik ki tamam bunun
hepsini bir yerde toplayabiliriz.
Ali Ercan'ın çok uzun yıllardır çalıştığı
İhtiyaç Haritası kısmı varmış aslında.
Harita base'i, haritanın üstünde
bunu görmek,
dolayısıyla keşke bütün çalışmaları
her yerde görebilsek
insanlar bir gönüllülük projesi
yapmak istediklerinde
bir günlüğüne olsun,
iki saatliğine olsun, hizmet vermek
istediklerinde bir günlüğüne,
iki saatliğine, üç saatliğine olsun,
ayda bir olsun, ayda iki olsun
hiç fark etmez,
katılabilecekleri bir yapı
hayal ediyordum.
O yapı Ali Ercan'ın fikriyle, Elif'in
fikriyle, Güler'in fikriyle birleşti
ve İhtiyaç Haritası öyle ortaya çıktı.
Bir buçuk yılın üzerinde
bir çalışma aslında ihtiyaç haritası.
Şimdi İhtiyaç Haritası,
İhtiyaç Haritası diyorum.
Bu da harita. Hazır görmüşken, üstünde
gördüğünüz noktaların bir kısmı ihtiyaç,
bir kısmı destek.
İhtiyaç haritası aslında
üç bölümden oluşuyor.
Bölüm demek belki yanlış olur
ama şöyle, ihtiyacı girmek.
Diyelim ki Bursa'da birisi ihtiyaç girdi,
bir tek orada girmemiş bu arada.
Eskişehir'de diyelim ki birisi ihtiyaç
girdi, o ihtiyacı görüyoruz.
Yukarıda bu ihtiyaçlar gibi o ihtiyacı
görüp o ilden destek giriyoruz.
Ya da başka bir ilden
o ihtiyacı görüp oraya destek giriyoruz.
Diyelim ki evimizde 300 tane kitap var
ya da teleskop var ve artık kullanmıyoruz.
Onu destek olarak giriyoruz
ve hiçbir zaman teleskobu
ihtiyacı olacağını düşünmeyen
bir okul öğretmeni,
"Ben çocuklara başka bir dünyanın da
varolduğunu göstermek istiyorum." deyip
Diyarbakır'dan o ihtiyacı, desteği
talep edip, ihtiyacını karşılayabiliyor.
Bir de gönüllülük var.
Üç demiştim, üç ayrı koldan oluşuyor.
Gönüllülük esası da şöyle, buraya
direkt giriyorsunuz, siteye giriyorsunuz,
bizimle telefonunuzu paylaşıyorsunuz.
Şimdi biraz doğrulamayı da güçlendirmek
için ilerleyen safhalarda
TC kimlik numarasıyla da
paylaşıma gideceğiz.
Çünkü şu anda hali hazırda daha iki
ay olmadan on beş binin üstünde
gönüllümüz oldu ve bu gönüllüler
şu esasla kabul ediliyorlar,
bütün bilgilerini paylaşıyorlar
ve paylaştıktan sonra da
bizim için çalışmayı taahhüt ediyorlar.
300 kitap gitti.
Fakat hesapladığı o 300
kitap değil, 250 kitapmış.
Oraya 250 kitap sığabildi ve bir
kısmı da fantastik kitaplardan oluşuyordu.
Dolayısıyla o 50 kitabı
kendisi ihtiyaç olarak girdi.
Yeniden bir destek olarak girdi.
Dolayısıyla ihtiyaç sahibine her zaman
ihtiyaç sahibi olarak bırakmayıp
tam tersine onun ne verebileceği,
onun bu sisteme ne katabileceği,
onun bu hayata ne katabileceğini
hep sorgulayan ve buna doğru iten
bir yapısı var.
Bir de şu var, İhtiyaç Haritası'nın
içinde herkes kurumsal yapılar içinde
çalışıyor, kimi yönetici, kimisi de
herhangi bir yerden sorumlu,
kimi IK biriminde çalışıyor.
Biz onlara da ulaşmaya çalışıyoruz.
Çünkü bunun bir örgütlülük ve
sürdürülebilir hal olması niyetindeyiz.
Onun için de liselerden tutun da
üniversitelere kadar birçok yerde,
İhtiyaç Haritası örgütlenmesi
oluşturmaya başlıyoruz.
Geçen hafta Bursa'da bir lisedeydim.
O lisenin yapısını kurduk.
Onlar başka, Bursa'daki diğer liselere
ulaşacaklar ve kontrollü biçimde liselerin
hepsinde bir İhtiyaç Haritası
örgütlenmesi kurmaya çalışıyoruz.
Geçtiğimiz hafta ekip olarak İzmir'deydik.
İzmir'deki dört üniversiteyle,
Yaşar Üniversitesi, Ekonomi Üniversitesi,
Ege ve Dokuz Eylül ile ortak görüştük.
Kiminin zaten hali hazırda bir sosyal
sorumluk çalışması var ve yürütüyor.
Kiminin hiç yoktu.
Şimdi onlarla birlikte yine yapılandık.
İçlerinde İhtiyaç Haritası ekipleri kurup
üniversitelerde yapmayı planlıyoruz
ve çok da iyi gidiyor.
Birçok üniversiteden talep var.
Sonrasında da daha yeni bir
İK sempozyumuna katıldık, Peryön'ün.
Orada da anlattık.
Bundan sonra Ankara'da,
Bursa'da, Antep'te anlatacağız.
Bu yapıyı kurmak istememizin, liseden
başlayıp üniversiteye, üniversiteden
iş hayatına kadar sürdürülebilir bir yapı
kurmak istememizin sebebi,
İhtiyaç Haritası'nı hem herkesin tanıması,
hem de aslında online imece
diyoruz biz buna,
bu online imece fikrini
kullanması, yaşatması.
Derdimiz herkesi İhtiyaç Haritası başlığı
altında toplamak değil,
herkesi İhtiyaç Haritası'nın
bir parçası yapmak ya da
İhtiyaç Haritası'nda bir şeyin
parçası yapmak.
Çünkü şöyle şeyler oluyor.
Birçok şirket, kurumsal sosyal sorumluluk
adına bir şeyler yapmak istiyor.
Fakat ya ihtiyacı olan doğru kişiyi
bulamıyorlar
ya o kadar gönüllü bulamıyorlar
ya da bu konuda profesyonel
bir destek alamamış oluyorlar.
Dolayısıyla ihtiyaç Haritası
bu projelerin ortak biçimde
buluşması için de iyi bir mecra.
Bir tarafıyla şunu anlatayım.
Gönüllerimiz arasında muhtarlar var,
kaymakamlar, valilikler, belediyeler.
Bunun yanı sıra o illerdeki
sivil toplum kuruluşları.
İhtiyaç haritası herkesle birlikte entegre
çalışabilecek bir yapıya sahip.
Bunun dışında.
Çok yaratıcı ihtiyaçlar da
gelebiliyor tabii.
Kimi zaman beyin isteyen de oluyor.
"Çocuğuma Playstation 4 alamıyorum
mağdurum, bir el atın." diyen oluyor.
Sevgilisine aşk talep eden oluyor.
Bir hak daha talep eden oluyor.
Neye dair bilmiyoruz.
Biz o taleplerin hepsine bakıyoruz.
Kalabalık da bir ekibiz ve bu ekip
onlara baktıktan sonra ihtiyaçlara,
bir adminimiz var, o onaylıyor.
Dolayısıyla bu biraz zaman alıyor.
Şimdi bu doğrulamayı
biraz daha kısaltmak için
şirketler bazında da
çalışmalar yürütüyoruz.
Mesela bir banka diyor ki
"Biz 81 ilde bütün şube çalışanlarımızla
sizin gönüllünüz olmak istiyoruz."
Biz de diyoruz ki "Bütün şube
değil de ikişer kişiyle olsun.
Başkalarına da yer açabilelim."
Bir şirket, isimlerini vermiyorum,
bütün depolarını, 45 deposunu bize açıp
bu depolarda kitap, yiyecek, gıda
saklayabileceğimizi taahhüt etti.
Fakat biz mesela ona harcadığımız
enerji yerine diyoruz ki
halihazırdaki bu ihtiyacı
biz kargo ile yollayalım.
Derdimiz aslında büyük tırlar,
büyük depolar, büyük kamyonlar
vesaire onu yönetmek değil.
Başta söylediğim gibi insanların buluşma
noktası olabilmek, online imece olabilmek.
Galiba söylemeyi atladığım
bir şey daha var, o da para.
Bizim üzerimizden hiç para geçmiyor.
Biz kimse tarafından desteklenmiyoruz.
Dördümüzün ortaya koyduğu bir bütçe var.
Bu yıl için ayırdığı.
Umarım ki bir sonraki yıl da ayıracağız.
O bütçeyle proje devam ediyor.
Projenin doğru biçimde sürdürülmesi için
bir mali planımız ve öngörümüz var.
Bununla da ilgili yapımız var
ama asla üzerimizden para dönmüyor.
Kimse bize para bağışlayamıyor.
Online imece dışında bir yapımız yok.
Onun dışında şöyle bir şey yapacağız.
Sadece kumbaralarımız oluşacak.
O da varolan dernekler
üzerinden oluşacak kumbaralar.
Dolayısıyla yine
bize bağışlanmamış olacak.
Eğer o proje bazında bir şey varsa
bir bağış, bir destek varsa,
kişi bunu desteklemiş olacak.
Ne kadar vaktim kaldı
acaba efendim on dakikaya?
Bir iki dakika tamam.
Bir de şu tarafını söyleyeyim.
Bir kurumla çalışma yapmak istemiştik.
Kendileri sahada çocuklarla çalışma
yapmak istiyordu.
İhtiyaç Haritası'ndan önce bu örneği
anlatacağım size, neden önemli olduğunu.
Sonra oturduk bana dediler ki,
"Mert Bey biz sizin
sosyal sorumluluk tarafınızı biliyoruz.
On ilde bir çalışma yapmak istiyoruz."
Ben dedim ki "Tamam, on ilde yapalım da
böyle bir çalışma,
bunu yapacak kişi ben değilim.
Bununla ilgili kurumlar var.
Ben ona destek olabilirim."
"Peki biz gönüllüleri
nereden bulacağız?" dedi.
"Nasıl gönüllüleri
nereden bulacaksınız?" dedim.
"Sizin şirketin içinde yok mu?"
"Var ama onları
nasıl koordine edeceğiz?"dedi.
"Tamam onu hallederiz herhalde." dedim.
"Peki çocukları nereden bulacağız?"
(Kahkaha)
"Çocukları vallahi bilemiyorum.
Bizim birkaç tanıdık var." falan.
Dolayısıyla böyle bir böyle bir yapı var.
Bir iyi niyet var.
Bunu aslında kınamak için anlatmıyorum.
İnsanlar bir şeyler yapmak istiyorlar
ama bu konuda organize değiliz.
Dolayısıyla İhtiyaç Haritası bunu
organize eden, bunun için yol gösteren,
"Bakın böyle dernekler var
bu çalışmaları yapan." diyen bir yer.
Her şeyi İhtiyaç Haritası
yapmak istemiyor.
Mesela öyle bir dernek var ki
ya da öyle bir site var ki,
online burs veriyor.
Öyle bir site var ki
online mimarlık atölyesi açmış.
Ona dair bir şey yapıyor.
"Kendi okulunu, kendi çevreni düzelt.
Topla, bak arızalarını gör." diyor.
Dolayısıyla biz o paslaşmanın
ve o yapıyı birlikte yürütmenin
derdindeyiz.
Bu anlamda birçok sivil
toplum kuruluşuyla görüştük.
Onların hesapları olacak
pek yakında burada.
Böyle devam eden bir yapı.
Hayal ettiğimiz kadar İhtiyaç Haritası ve
kimsenin de sahibi olmadığı bir yapı.
Online imece olarak umarım
sürdürülebilirliğini devam ettirecek.
Şimdi sorularınızla ilerleyelim.
Şunu da söyleyim isterseniz ilk başta,
biz İhtiyaç Haritası'nı çok kuvvetli
bir internet temeliyle kurmadık,
elimizden geleni yaptık.
Tabii ki her sistem gibi zaafları oluyor
ama bunu Aralık ayına kadar
yapmamızın sebebi şuydu:
Bu bir beta versiyon.
Bu beta versiyonun da neye
izin verdiğini göreceğiz.
Çünkü bir canlı yayına çıkıyoruz,
bir konuşma oluyor,
daha çünkü tamamen
tanıtmaya başlamadık.
İnsanlar on bin kişi bir giriyor,
site çöküyor.
Şimdi o kadar güçlü değil.
25 günde 120 bin, 130
bine yakın insan girdi ilk 25 günde,
sonraki verileri
şu anda tam bilmiyorum.
Çokça ihtiyaç karşılandı.
300'ün üzerinde,
şu anda gördüğünüz gibi.
Galiba bu online.
1.606 ihtiyaç var.
202 destek.
Şimdi sorularla galiba
benim unuttuğum şeyleri,
bana hatırlatıp
yeniden devam etmiş olacağız.